today we're talking about the newly
announced nvidia gpus how halo is
helping split gate and more
to kick off ces nvidia announced its
newest gpu the rtx
3090ti or tie
but i like saying ti which has 24
gigabytes of gddr6x
vram at 21 gigabytes per second making
it faster than the rtx 3090. during a
presentation nvidia management called
the gpu a monster and boasted that it
will have 40 teraflops of performance
compared to the 36 teraflops for the rtx
3090. it also has 78 teraflops for ray
tracing and
teraflops for ai tasks don't you just
love the word teraflops
no
just me
okay nvidia didn't share any of the key
details for the rtx 3090ti like its
price or release date but for comparison
the rtx 3090 launched at 1 500
nvidia says to expect more information
about the rtx 3090ti next month during
an event nvidia also announced the rtx
3050 which launches later this month for
just 250
cheaper than nvidia's rtx 3060 although
it's not likely that you'll find a card
for that price the company said users
will be able to play modern titles with
ray tracing at over 60 frames per second
using the rtx 3050 although at 1080p and
not 4k
the rtx 3050 will include 8 gigabytes of
gddr6 memory a sizeable amount
considering it's relatively low msrp
comparatively amd's new rx 6500 costs
just 200. which will likely struggle
with ray tracing any games at 1080p and
only sports 4 gigabytes of gddr6 memory
now let's move right along from hardware
to some software the arena shooter split
gate drew immediate comparisons to old
school halo multiplayer when it released
in beta last summer but while the
release of halo infinite's free-to-play
multiplayer could have been an
existential threat for split gate 1047
co-founder ian pruitt thinks it might
have actually helped the game's
popularity prue told the loadout that he
was never worried about halo eating into
split gate sales and in fact halo seems
to have given split gate a nice boost on
playstation prue said that the split
gate player count on playstation has
gone up since halo infinite launched in
november possibly suggesting that
playstation owners went looking for a
similar arena shooter experience prue
said quote i'm actually glad halo
infinite is out i honestly think that in
the long run halo infinite and split
gate will help each other i think that
there's just so much noise in so many
battle royales right now and these two
games are bringing people over to the
arena shooter genre
and now let's talk about game pass
microsoft has announced the first wave
of game pass titles for 2022 and the
company is kicking off the new year with
a bang game pass titles available today
january 4th include the hand-drawn
puzzle game gora goa as well as the
castaway game or leah and the 2.5 d side
scroller the pedestrian on january 6
game pass will add mass effect legendary
edition for game pass ultimate
subscribers on console and pc
additionally january 6 marks the launch
of the multiplayer fire focus game ember
while the acclaimed action adventure
game outer wilds arrives that day as
well january 13th we'll see the
roguelike spelunky 2 launch as well as 4
player first person shooter the
anacrusis which is a day 1 release and
will initially be available in game
preview two days later on january 15th a
handful of games are leaving game pass
like kingdom hearts 3 and pandemic if
only the real pandemic could leave on
the 15th
also don't forget you can claim
january's playstation plus games right
now these titles include dirt 5 deep
rock galactic and persona 5 strikers all
of these games will be available until
february 1st so go claim them right now
and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]